like two lives respected professor but
then all of a sudden he became like this
huge rock star this huge personality i
was always curious to the effects of
that on an individual it was pretty
rough and he's said this himself i was
so used to one way of living like one
life that i can't understand this one
which is fair because it is pretty weird
it's weird to walk down the street and
have people recognizing it's weird for
the media to portray you as someone who
you aren't it's hard to wrap your mind
around as it is but i think the older
you are the harder it is but he hasn't
changed when i was little i still got
all the lessons that he's teaching
people now and the way he lectures too
is the same way he lectured in
university classrooms but now he's
lecturing on stage it hasn't changed him
and it hasn't changed how he is at home
or like in his personal life either he
was always pretty eccentric which isn't
something i recognized
until probably he got more famous and
was like oh other dads aren't really
like